So again now,
let's look at the whole approach again.
And the same steps but
different details.
Compute the Gaussian derivatives at
each pixel, for each and every image,
that's what we want to do.
Second thing we want to do is
compute the second moment matrix
in a Gaussian window around each pixel.
Again, find a pixel and going through
this whole image, find a small region
and compute the second moment matrix,
because now we have the derivatives.
We know how to do this.
And again we want to compute
this within a window.
Then using that, remember how we can
actually take R, or compute R from M,
by looking at it's trace and
it's determinant, we can compute R.
We want to do a little
bit of thresholding on R,
because we don't want to just completely
live off the details that we had.
Remember we showed you that
with the example image two.
The bright white spots
will convert into small,
white dots which were hard to see.
Then finally find a local
maxima of the response function
by using a non-maximum suppression.
And that basically now
starts giving us features.
Now we have found
features in two images,
which we now can be using to
match between those two images.